JENNY BROWN: Welcome back
to Cloud Storage Bytes.
Now that you've got
the billing basics,
let's add a level
of complexity, like
when a client needs to
be billed for their usage
of your resources.
Today on Cloud
Storage Bytes, we'll
take you into the world
of Requester Pays.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whenever a user accesses
a Cloud Storage resource,
like a bucket or
an object, there
are charges associated with
both making and executing
the request.
This includes operation
charges for performing
a request, network charges
for reading the data,
and data retrieval
charges if the data
is stored as nearline
storage or coldline storage.
Now, normally the project
owner of the resource
is billed for these
access charges.
But this isn't
always appropriate.
If the requester provides
a billing project
with their request,
the requester's project
can be billed instead.
And this feature
is appropriately
called Requester Pays.
With Requester Pays
enabled on your bucket,
you can require requesters
to include a billing project
in their request, thus billing
the requester's project.
Enabling Requester
Pays is useful.
For example, if you
have a lot of data
that you want to make
available to your users,
but you don't want to be charged
for their access of that data.
Note that there are some
charges that are always
going to be applied to the
project containing the bucket,
even when Requester
Pays is enabled.
These charges include
storage charges
for storing data in a bucket and
any applicable early deletion
charges.
For complete details
on those caveats,
go ahead and check out
the docs linked below.
And now, let's look into how
to enable Requester Pays.
Start in the Cloud
Storage browser
in the Google Cloud
Platform Console.
In the list of buckets,
find the bucket
that you want to
enable and click
the Off button in the
Requester Pays column.
In the window that
appears, click Enable.
Once enabled, a
green bubble and On
will appear in the Requester
Pays column for that bucket.
Of course, once you
enable Requester Pays,
you may need to disable it.
So let's walk through
that process as well.
To disable Requester
Pays on a bucket,
go ahead and start in the Cloud
Storage browser in the Google
Cloud Platform Console.
In the list of buckets,
find the bucket
you want to disable and click
the On button in the Requester
Pays column.
In the window that
appears, click Disable.
Once disabled, a
gray bubble and Off
will appear in the
Requester Pays column.
To check whether Requester
Pays is enabled on a bucket,
take a look at the
list of buckets.
The Requester Pays
status of each bucket
is found in that
Requester Pays column.
So we've looked at how
to enable and disable
Requester Pays on your
own storage buckets.
But what if you're
on the other side?
What if you're the
account who wants
to access an object stored
in a Requester Pays bucket?
Let's check out
accessing Requester Pays
buckets using gsutil.
Here's how to include
a billing project
that you can download an object
stored in a Requester Pays
bucket.
Project ID is the ID of
the project to be billed.
For example, my-project.
Bucket name is the name
of the relevant bucket.
For example, my-bucket.
Object name is the name of the
object you want to download.
For example, pets/dog.
Object destination
is the location where
you want to save your object.
For example, desktop/dog.
Keep in mind that buckets that
have Requester Pays disabled
still accept requests that
include a billing project.
And charges are applied to
the billing project supplied
in the request.
So make sure you consider
any billing implications
prior to including a
billing project in any
of your requests.
There's more to come
about Cloud Storage,
but that's going to be
for another episode.
If you want to know more
about using Requester Pays,
check out the links
in the description.
Don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
Quick Byte of Cloud Storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]